[Musique]
la semaine européenne du développement
durable est lancée et tous les acteurs
publics associatifs mais également des
collégiens et lycéens se sont retrouvés
dans l'hémicycle du département pour
promouvoir ensemble les actions locales
en faveur du développement durable le
département a rappelé ses grands projets
de transition écologique comme le plan
négawatt qui vise à faire de la
collectivité une collectivité à énergie
positive et le projet de reboisement du
territoire le plus grand thé exemple
c'est le plan un million d'hommes avec
une participation citoyenne
participation des collégiens de nos
services va de la population à ce plan
nous voulons faire en sorte que le
territoire soit verdoyant lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique decc les
dérèglements thématique c'est aussi
redonner de la force à la nature
réunionnaise reboiser massivement les
forêts les quartiers les espaces urbains
d'espèces indigènes et endémiques de la
réunion c'est l'ambition de ce plan un
million d'arbres des collégiens et
lycéens ont été récompensés pour leur
travail artistique sur ces affiches qui
témoigne de leur engagement à la
protection de notre île et de notre
planète
reflet de la goutte d'eau et il ya le
volcan c est en dessous il ya des pays
et la réunion en rouge est aussi la
petite ville et des gens qui prend le
vélo et du bus et aussi il quand yvon
marché pour les ventes de vin quand le
conseil départemental des jeunes se
mobilisent également avec une grande
concertation entre tous ses membres sur
l'adaptation au changement climatique
comment répondre aux enjeux climatiques
de demain donc on a notre grand débat
finale locale le 24 donc la semaine
prochaine et ensuite cinq jeunes du cdj
donc seront choisis pour justement mener
nos propositions pour lutter contre les
enjeux climatiques
à l'assemblée nationale le 20 novembre
prochain
du 18 septembre au 8 octobre la semaine
du développement durable valorise et
encourage l'engagement de tous pour agir
au quotidien à la transition écologique
[Musique]